listening to
Dave and Brandon
I'm away
as an artist when you look at things
like that as a painter or a writer or
poet or whatever it's um it's actually
really a good approach is to sort of
saying how few words can I use and if
you look at the big catch phrases that
you know you mentioned already like
almost all the biggest most powerful ad
campaigns of all time or like to word
things or three word things like like
you know I just do it or got milk or
think different or or the first one of
that which was really think small back
in nineteen fifty-nine when they
introduced Volkswagen and it's you know
it seems so easy like yeah whatever you
say those words up there but but they
take months and months of thought and
when they work it's something to kind of
marvel at